[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta slomker guten Abend
das war ein Schlag mit Ankündigung als
die USA und Großbritannien letzte Nacht
Ziele im Jemen bombardierten über Wochen
hatte man mehr oder weniger zugesehen
wie die huthis drohen und Raketen auf
Handelsschiffe schossen womit dieser
zentrale internationale seweg drohte
unpassierbar zu werden es war klar dass
die USA irgendwann reagieren wobei sie
dabei nicht nur westliche Interessen
vertreten allerdings haben die huthis
einen sehr mächtigen Verbündeten Iran
und das machte diese Krise so riskant
und die huthis sind auch längst keine
turnschuhkrieger mehr
sie verfügen über moderne Raketen und
andere Waffen und bieten selbst einer
hochgerüsteten Regionalmacht wie
Saudi-Arabien seit Jahren erfolgreich
die Stirn hiilke Petersen
berichtet
taifunkampfjets der Royal Air Force sie
starten vergangene Nacht aus
Zypern auch die usstitkräfte sind auf
dem Weg Amerika führt den Militäreinsatz
im Jemen gegen Stellungen der Husi
Milizen
die hatten alle internationalen
Warnungen ignoriert der Husi Sender
zeigt die
Einschläge verhältnismäßig und gezielt
so beschreibt der britische
Premierminister sunak die Schläge er ist
heute in der Ukraine unterwegs will erst
am Montag vor dem Parlament erklären
warum die schnelle Entscheidung über
Nacht getroffen
wurde wir haben gemeinsam mit unseren
Verbündeten eine Reihe von Angriffen
durchgeführt die die Stellung die wir
ins Visier genommen haben Sch
haben dürften erste Zeichen deuten
darauf hin dass unsere Angriffe
erfolgreich
waren seit Beginn des Gazakrieges
attackieren die vom Iran unterstützten
Husi Milizen die internationale
Schiffahrt im Roten Meer wollen so Druck
machen gegen Israel um die Hamas zu
unterstützen für die Handelsschiffahrt
ist die Region seither brandgefährlich
mehr als 10% des Welthandels gehen
üblicherweise durchs Rote Meer jetzt
navigieren viele Schiffe um den
afrikanischen Kontinent herum das dauert
10 Tage länger sprengt Lieferketten und
treibt die Kosten nach
oben fast 200.000 bewaffnete hui Kämpfer
gibt es seit 2014 im Bürgerkrieg gegen
die Regierung des Jemen und deren
arabische Verbündete sie nennen sich
Achse des Widerstands gegen Israel die
USA den Westen in der Hauptstadt Sanaa
unterstützen heute ztausende die hussi
Rebellen und die Welt guckt
[Musik]
hin das ist das allererste Mal dass sie
sich international präsentieren als
Organisation die in der Lage ist die
globale Wirtschaft nachhaltig zu
stören aus Sicht der Husi Miliz ein
Erfolg der Kampf gegen große
Mächte die Demonstration heute ist auch
eine Botschaft speziell an
Großbritannien und die USA dass sie für
die Angriffe einen hohen Preis zahlen
werden iierten wollen die Rebellen
Schwächen vor allem aber meinen sie
deren Schutzmacht
Iran die indirekte Botschaft an den Iran
die von den USA kommt und von
Großbritannien unterstützt wird wir
wollen keinen
Krieg Iran aber soll wissen sie werden
nicht einfach
zugucken wir wissen dass Iran Rebellen
unterstützt dass sie ausrüsten Raketen
und Drohnen wir haben klar gemacht Iran
muss damit
aufhören eskalieren wollle Amerika den
Konflikt nicht doch die Region und das
Rote Meer ist wohl längst ein
Nebenkriegsschauplatz in der
gazakrise schalten wir noch zu unserer
Korrespondentin Claudia Bates in
Washington Claudia wird in USA damit
gerechnet dass sich huis und Iran jetzt
hinlänglich beeindruckt zeigen oder
rechnet man mit
mehr
also zunächst mal war es Präsident Biden
und seinen Verbündeten wichtig zu sagen
jetzt reicht's und Biden selbst sagt es
bleibt nicht bei dem einen Mal wenn die
militärangriffe Ihre gewünschten Ziele
nicht erreichen und das heißt keine
Angriffe der huis mehr im Roten Meer
ansonsten wird es weitere Konsequenzen
geben daran lässt die US-Regierung gar
keinen Zweifel in Militärkreisen sieht
man das auch als deutlichen Warnschuss
gegenüber dem Iran dem eine
internationale Allianz jetzt deutlich
sagt halt dich raus halt dich zurück da
Iran schon anspricht wie hoch wird denn
das eskalationsrisiko
eingeschätzt also das Weiße Haus hat
betont man suche nicht den Konflikt mit
dem Iran und Joe Biden sagte gerade auch
Iran wolle auch keinen Krieg mit den USA
natürlich sieht man hier dieses Risiko
aber man hält es offenbar für
beherrschbar die USA rechnen wohl mit
einer Reaktion der huthis aber
befürchten wohl kein flächenbran und es
gibt wirklich auch nichts woran die US
Regierung angesichts der Wahlen hier im
nächsten Jahr ein geringeres Interesse
haben könnte Joe Biden hat von Anfang an
betont dass eine Eskalation unbedingt
vermieden werden muss und sieht diese
Militärschläge jetzt offenbar nicht in
einem Gegensatz zu dieser Haltung werden
diese Militärschläge denn auch von den
Republikanern mitgetragen also
Handelswege freizuhalten Israel zu
schützen dass das wäre ja früher eine
Selbstverständlichkeit für die Republik
er gewesen aber solche Gewissheiten
haben sich ja doch etwas
aufgelöst ja bei den Republikanern ist
die Unterstützung für Israel weiterhin
sehr groß und auch bei diesen Schlägen
gegen die huthis jetzt haben sich
toprepublikaner hinter den Präsidenten
gestellt und fanden den Militärschlag
überfällig auch in der Hoffnung dass Joe
Biden gegenüber Iran wieder die
Abschreckung herstellt die die
Republikaner für notwendig halten also
ein seltener Moment der Unterstützung
für Joe Biden vom politischen Gegner
diesmal danke schön Claudia nach
Washington ja scha man sich die
Landkarte an dann sieht sich Israel
jedenfalls gleich von mehreren Seiten
durch Verbündete Irans unmittelbar
attackiert von der Hizbollah im Norden
der Hamas im Westen und im Süden von den
huthis die über Raketen verfügen die bis
zu Israels Urlaubsort Elat reichen das
ist keine angenehme Situation für ein
Land von sehr überschaubar
Größe aber Israel steht ja nicht nur
militärisch unter Druck auf der
Weltbühne tobt eine zweite Schlacht die
mit anderen Mitteln geführt wird dazu
gehört auch das Verfahren vor dem
Internationalen Gerichtshof in Den Hag
dass die Republik Südafrika mit ihrer
Klage gegen Israel initiiert hat gestern
am ersten Tag vor Gericht hatten nur die
Ankläger also die Anwälte Südafrikas das
Wort heute verteidigte sich Israel
berichtet es ist die wichtigste Meldung
in den Fernsehnachrichten israel steht
in Den Haag vor Gericht wegen des
Vorwurfs des Völkermordes an
Palästinensern in Gaza ein empörter
Regierungschef netanah wirft Südafrika
himmelschreiende Heuchelei
vor wir kämpfen gegen Terroristen wir
kämpfen gegen Lügen gegen Terroristen
die ungeheure Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit begangen haben die Kinder
Frauen Rentner erm verbrannt
vergewaltigt geköpft haben
ähnlich deutlich auch Israels
Klageerwiderung heute in den Hag
Südafrikas Anschuldigungen seien
faktisch falsch eine vorsätzliche
Verzerrung des tatsächlichen
Konflikts als Antwort auf die
hamasmassaker vom 7 Oktober die
andauernden Angriffe aus Gaza und Hamas
Ankündigungen solche Massaker zu
wiederholen hat Israel das Recht
Maßnahmen zur Verteidigung seiner Bürger
und zur Befreiung der Geiseln zu
ergreifen
israel führt einen Verteidigungskrieg
gegen Hamas nicht gegen das
palästinensische
Volk Argumente so glaubt der
Völkerrechtler Professor groß die das
Gericht eigentlich überzeugen müssten er
sieht keine rechtliche Grundlage für die
Klage es sein weder Absicht noch Vorsatz
erkennbar ich glaube nicht dass dem
Gericht ausreichend Beweise dafür
vorliegen dass Israel einen Völkermord
begeht oder
vorbereitet verbittert verfolgen viele
in Israel den Prozess in den Hag während
zahlreiche Familien seit d Monaten um
Leben und Gesundheit von mehr als 130
Geiseln in der Hand der Hamas
Terroristen bangen fühlen sie sich zu
Unrecht
angeprangert die wissen genau welche
Grausamkeiten die Hamas hier verübt hat
aber sie schauen weg wenn es um Juden
geht spricht man
anders für mich ist das Doppelmoral die
einen dürfen das was die anderen nicht
dürfen
das Gericht wird vermutlich schon
kommende Woche über eine vorläufige
Anordnung urteilen deren Umsetzung ist
zwar kaum zu erzwingen der politische
Schaden einer Verurteilung aber wäre für
Israel
beträchtlich israel steht als Beklagter
da und muss sich verteidigen das ist
schon Schaden genug weil wir nachweisen
müssen dass wir nicht schuldig sind das
ist ein
Problem Israels Armee setzt unterdessen
ihre Operationen vor allem im Süden des
Streifens
fort und vor dem Hintergrund all dieser
Krisen in der Welt schauen wir auf die
politische Stimmung in Deutschland und
da wird's dann auch nicht fröhlicher was
sich im aktuellen ztf Politbarometer
niederschlägt die Zahlen sind vor allem
für die Ampelkoalition ein Disaster aber
sie werfen auch strategische Fragen an
die Union auf zumal im September
Landtagswahlen anstehen nach denen
möglicherweise eine große Ratlosigkeit
darüber herrschen wird wer da überhaupt
noch mit WM kann wenn am nächsten
Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre käme die SPD
nur noch auf 13%. so schwach war sie
seit dem Amtsantritt von Olaf Scholz
noch nie CDU CSU kä mit leichtem Verlust
auf
31%. die grün und verändert auf 14 die
FDP würde mit 4% aus dem Bundestag
fliegen die AFD käme auf
22% die linke und die Freien Wähler
würden beide an der 5% Hürde scheinen
ebenso die frisch gegründete Partei
Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht die hier
vorerst nur auf 4% käme aber laut
Umfragen Potenzial für mehr hat das sind
zwar nur Momentaufnahmen aber sie haben
es in sich Christiane
hübscher die Ampel ist kaputt was in
diesen Tagen vieler Orts auf bauerndemos
zu lesen und zu hören ist trifft
offenbar die Stimmung vieler im Land die
Bundesregierung mache ihre Arbeit gut
sagen nur noch 27
schlecht finden
69% die Zahlen sind schlecht sie gehen
vor allem auch weiter nach unten und das
ist das gefährliche wir haben es mit
drei Partnern zu tun die eben nicht
wirklich gut zueinander passen und die
deswegen auch sich so schwer tun jetzt
auf diese große Unzufriedenheit zu
reagieren dabei war die Zufriedenheit
mit der Ampel zu Beginn des
ukrainekriegs mal durchaus hoch der
doppelwums von Scholz gab noch mal einen
kleinen Schub mit dem heizungsstreit
aber stürzt die Regierung ab seit dem
haushaltsurteil geht es weiter bergab
dabei herrscht bei den beteiligten
Parteien offenbar kein
Erkenntnisproblem warum haben wir
Vertrauen verloren wir haben uns als
Ampel letzten zwei Jahren zu oft
gegenseitig das Bein gestellt da wir
Kompromisse gefunden haben dann aber wir
selbst zerredet haben jüngstes Beispiel
Landwirtschaftsminister chem öemir der
sich ausgebut von den Landwirten mit
ihnen solidarisiert gegen die eigene
Regierung ich habe die Beschlüsse gehört
und ich habe gesagt liebe Freunde von
den Koalitionsspitzen diese Beschlüsse
kann ich so nicht mittragen als
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister in Sachsen
wo die SPD in Umfragen bei nur noch 3%
steht erwarten Sie mehr Führung von
Berlin dass man vielleicht nicht jede
Meinungsverschiedenheit nach außen
tragen muss was soll den den Bürger
sagen wenn Politikerinnen und Politiker
keine Lösungen finden denn die sind ja
für diese Lösung gewählt worden gemeint
ist auch der Kanzler Olaf Scholz wird
abgestraft 60% der deutschen bewerten
seine Arbeit mittlerweile als schlecht
ein neuer Tiefstwert da sehen wir auch
tatsächlich dass der Haus der
Haushaltsstreit ihm auch persönlich
wirklich geschadet hat dass seine
Kompetenz in Frage steht dass die
Menschen ihm eben nicht mehr in dem Maße
vertrauen wie zuvor die drei
ampelparteien erreichen zusammen gerade
noch so viel Zustimmung wie die Union
31%. die ruft seit Wochen nach Neuwahlen
wissend dass die wohl kaum kommen werden
so bleibt ihr nur machtlose daueramp der
Vizekanzler hat die tagemal gesagt sie
wären umzingelt von Wirklichkeit
deswegen wäre das alles so schwierig in
Wahrheit ist diese Regierung entkoppelt
von der Wirklichkeit die lebt in ihrer
eigenen Wirklichkeit das macht die
Menschen so wütend für die neuegründete
wagenknechtpartei sieht das
Politbarometer ein Potenzial von
21%. vor allem linke und AFD könnten
Wähler an das neue linkspopulistische
Bündnis verlieren die Unzufriedenheit
mit den klassischen Akteuren der
Parteipolitik führt dazu dass diese
anderen Kräfte eben Zulauf bekommen und
nicht unbedingt die größte
Oppositionspartei die Union die AFD
bleibt wie festgetackert auf Platz 2 in
den Umfragen unklar ob die jüngsten
Enthüllungen über Geheimtreffen mit
rechtsradikalen der Partei Schaden
werden fest steht heute nur die deutsche
Parteienlandschaft ist in
Bewegung das ganze Politbarometer dann
am Ende des heute Journals und bereits
jetzt jederzeit online abrufbar auf ZDF
heute laut Politbarometer gibt es in der
Bevölkerung übrigens deutlich mehr
Verständnis für die
bauernproteste als für den Streik bei
der Bahn und mit dem Thema geht's jetzt
bei dir weiter Heinz ja der Streik der
lockführergewerkschaft GDL bei der
Deutschen Bahn ist seit dem Abend
beendet aber es ist unklar wie es nun
weitergeht in diesem Tarifkonflikt die
Bahn forderte die GDL zu Verhandlungen
auf die GDL erklärte die Bahn könne mit
einem substanziellen Angebot an den
Verhandlungstisch zurückkehren und
drohte mit weiteren Streiks für morgen
teilte die Deutsche Bahn erst einmal mit
man bereite sich darauf vor im
Personenverkehr wieder das normale
Angebot zu
fahren die Proteste der Bauern gegen die
geplante Streichung von Subventionen für
die Landwirtschaft gingen auch heute
weiter in Nürnberg demonstrierten etwa
5000 Landwirte auf dem Volksfestplatz
csuchef Söder sagte ihnen erneut seine
volle Unterstützung zu und machte die
ampelpolitik für die Probleme der Bauern
verantwortlich bundesagrahminister
ötimir verwies dagegen im ZDF auf
Verfehlungen der unionsgeführten
Vorgängerregierungen und rief zu
gemeinsamen Lösungen für die
Landwirtschaft
auf Großbritannien hat seine
militärische Unterstützung für die
Ukraine auf rund 2,9 Milliarden Euro für
das kommende Haushaltsjahr ab April
aufgestockt mit dem Geld sollen unter
anderem tausende Kampfdrohnen und
Raketen finanziert werden beide Seiten
unterzeichneten zudem beim Besuch des
britischen Premiers sunak in Kiev ein
Abkommen über die Zusammenarbeit im
Sicherheitsbereich es solle gelten bis
das osteuropäische Land der NATO
Beitritt sagte der ukrainische Präsident
selenski die unom Mission in Afghanistan
hat sich besorgt geäußert über
Festnahmen von Frauen und Mädchen die
sich nicht an die kleideordnung der
Taliban gehalten haben sollen seit
Jahresbeginn habe es in zwei Provinzen
staatliche Kampagnen zur Durchsetzung
der Verschleierung bis auf die Augen
gegeben besonders religiöse und
ethnische Minderheiten seien von den
Festnahmen
betroffen Ausicht der Machthaber in
Peking ist die Sache ja eindeutig den
Fall Hong Kong haben Sie erfolgreich
erledigt nun bleibt nur noch Taiwan als
demokratisches Ärgernis vor der eigenen
Haustür dass ich die Volksrepublik den
Inselstaat über kurz oder lang
einverleiben will da steht außer Frage
daraus wird in Peking ja auch gar kein
Hel gemacht die Frage ist nur wann und
wie
eine militärische großinvasion wie
Wladimir Putin sie in der Ukraine befahl
ist nicht die einzige Möglichkeit
insofern sind die Wahlen morgen in
Taiwan schon von weltpolitischer
Bedeutung gelingt es der China
freundlichen Opposition das Ruder zu
übernehmen wäre das für Peking schon mal
ein immenser Erfolg den es auch mit
allen propagandistischen Mitteln zu
befördern versucht Miriam Steimer ist
für uns in
Taiwan viel los am Bahnhof in taipe denn
wer in Taiwan seine Stimme abgeben will
kann das nur persönlich im Wahllokal und
zwar dort wo er registriert ist Ariel
Chang muss dafür an die
Ostküste das ist mein Recht dass die
Demokratie mir gibt das muss ich
wahrnehmen das ist wichtig für Taiwan
hier bin ich aufgewachsen hier werde ich
leben den Bus der erstwählerin hat ein
Verein organisiert der Junge Wählerinnen
und Wähler zur stimmabgab motivieren
will ein Ticket kostet 3,30 € egal
wohin die Wahlen in Taiwan sind der
einzige freie politische Wettbewerb in
der chinesischsprachigen Welt Taiwans
Demokratie ist eine Herausforderung für
Festland
China wie gerade erst wieder in der
Neujahrsansprache wird Staats und
parteichf chiden Ping nicht müde zu
betonen dass er Taiwan nicht als eigenen
Staat sondern als abtrünnige Provinz
betrachtet er lässt sein Militär rund um
die Insel immer häufiger den Angriff
proben seit 8 Jahren gibt es keine
offiziellen Kontakte zwischen Festland
China und Taiwan und das könnte so
weitergehen denn laut Umfragen ist er
der Favorit William lei der bisherige
Vizepräsident von der regierenden
Fortschrittspartei die chinesische
Staatsführung bezeichnet ihn als
gefährlichen Separatisten ihr wäre ein
Präsident der Peking freundlicheren KMT
lieber der liegt laut der letzten
Umfrage nur wenige Prozentpunkte
hinterlei dazu will China die Wahlen
beeinflussen Hackerangriffe und
Desinformationskampagnen haben laut
Taiwans Behörden massiv zugenommen
Peking investiert viel Geld um Taiwans
Jugend zu erreichen auch via videoapps
wie
tiktok da werden immer nur die schönen
Seiten von China gezeigt negative Dinge
wie Tibet shinjang Hongkong
Sicherheitsgesetz und andere
Menschenrechts
ti
nicht sie macht sich Sorgen dass China
nicht nur militärisch angreifen könnte
sondern durch den Einfluss via Social
Media auch Taiwans Identität
bedroht der Informationskrieg hat längst
begonnen da haben wir keinen Frieden
mehr in seinen zivilschutzkursen die
immer mehr Taiwaner besuchen geht es
deshalb auch nicht nur um
Selbstverteidigung oder der Erste Hilfe
sondern auch darum Falschinformationen
und den Versuch von Beeinflussung zu
erkennen ja und geopolitisch kehren wir
jetzt noch mal zurück zum Krisenherd am
Roten Meer mit dem Beschuss dieser
Handelsroute durch die hies Hein das ist
bei dir jetzt noch mal Thema an der
Börse ja diese Route verbindet über den
Sueskanal den Indischen Ozean mit dem
Mittelmeer ist also eine zentrale
Handelsstraße die Situation dort hat
bereits wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen in
welchem Umfang Valerie Haller wie wird
die Lage wirtschaftlich eingeschätzt ja
also das hat erstmal große Wirkung auf
den Warenverkehr und man wird es
vermutlich auch bald in den Regalen
merärken viele räereihen leiten den
Verkehr nun um das dauert deutlich
länger und ist deutlich teurer kostete
ein Container von Asien nach Europa
Anfang November 1500 € sind es
inzwischen 4000 €. schon Ikea und Aldi
hatten gewarnt dass sich einzelne Ware
verspäten könnte nun stoppt Tesla in
grünnheide im Januar seine
e-autoproduktion für zwei Wochen weil
Akkus aus China fehlen auch Volvo
produziert ein paar Tage lang nicht
Sorge gilt nun auch den Öltransporten
die über das Rote Meer laufen das treibt
den Ölpreis in der Spitze heute um rund
3%. auf die Verbraucherpreise wird sich
die Unruhe auf den seehandelsruten
vermutlich nicht groß auswirken die
Frachtraten machen nur einen
verhältnismäßig kleinen Teil des Preises
aus bei den waren deutsche
Autohersteller wie BMW und VW sind von
den Lieferengpässen weniger betroffen
sie beziehen viele Teile inzwischen aus
Europa eine Lehre aus der coronapandemie
werie Haller vielen
Dank Fußballlegende Franz Beckenbauer
der am vergangenen Sonntag im Alter von
78 Jahren gestorben war ist auf einem
Münchner Friedhof beigesetzt worden die
Beerdigung fand im engsten Familienkreis
statt am Abend wird mit der FC Bayern
München das erste Bundesligaspiel des
Jahres der Verstorbenen vereinsikone vor
Beginn der Partie gab es eine
schweigemin im anstrrokreis zeigte ein
Bild Beckenbauer mit seiner fünf auf dem
Trikot und dieses erste Bundesligaspiel
des Jahres ist inzwischen zu Ende Bayern
hat 3:0 gegen Hoffenheim
gewonnen Lea Sophie Friedrich hat bei
der Bahnrad EM in den Niederlanden im
sprintturnier Silber gewonnen sie ging
als Titelverteidigerin ins Finale verlor
das aber gegen die Britin Emma finuken
die damit neue Europameisterin ist
bronze ging an Emma
Hinze gefrierender Sprühregen und
Glatteis haben in Teilen Deutschlands zu
Unfällen geführt der Deutsche
Wetterdienst warnt bis morgen Vormittag
vor Glätte und Frost nach Polizeiangaben
kamen zwei Menschen ums Leben im
Landkreis Oldenburg verunglückte ein
29-jähriger tödlich als er mit seinem
Auto von einer winterglatten Straße
abkam in anderen Landesteilen wurden
mehrere Menschen verletzt
über das neue Politbarometer haben wir
ja schon berichtet jenseits der
Sonntagsfrage bietet es noch eine ganze
Reihe anderer Erkenntnisse über die
Stimmungslage im Land und die
präsentiert ihn jetzt Matthias
vnov guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer der Januar ist die Zeit
für ne Staats und für gute Vorsätze mit
voller Motivation also ins neue Jahr das
wird auch politisch gerade gebraucht
denn das neue Jahr beginnt wie das alte
endete turbulent die Bundesregierung
muss sich sputen in
2024 nicht vollends den Anschluss zu
verlieren wenn am nächsten Sonntag
wirklich Bundestagswahl wäre käme die
SPD nur noch auf 13% -1 ihr neuer
Tiefstwert in dieser Legislaturperiode
CDU CSU 31% ebenfalls -1 die Grünen
unverändert 14 die FDP jetzt
4-1 AFD 22 die Linke 4 beide unverändert
Freie Wähler 4 + 1 das Bündnis Sara
Wagenknecht BSW startet ebenfalls bei
4%. damit wären gleich vier Parteien
unter der 5% Hürde und nicht im
Bundestag so könnte ein Fünftel aller
Stimmen außen vorbleleiben und die
Schwelle für Mehrheiten deutlich sinken
wie das BSW sich entwickelt bleibt
abzuwarten aktuell zeigt sich für die
Partei ein relativ großes
Potenzial 4% wollen die neue Partei auf
jeden Fall wählen 17% wahrscheinlich 27%
wahrscheinlich nicht und 47% wollen das
neue Bündnis auf keinen Fall
wählen wehtun könnte die Partei vor
allem der Linken und der AFD unter ihren
Anhängern finden sich
überdurchschnittlich viele potentielle
bswwähler kommen wir zu unserer Top 10
also der Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung auf der Skala von
+5 bis -5 belegt alies Weidel den
letzten Platz - 2,3 etwas schlechter als
im Dezember davor nennt sie fäer 1,2
etwas besser Olaf Scholz ebenfalls
-1,2 Christian Lindner -1,1 beide
schwächer beide mit ihrem bisher
schlechtesten Wert Sarah Wagenknecht
legt dagegen zu
-0,9 Robert habbeck schlechter -0,8
ebenfalls ein persönlicher Negativrekord
Anna Lena berbock -0,7 und Friedrich
März
-0,3 Markus Söder 0,0 alle schlechter
und Spitzenreiter bleibt Boris Pistorius
1,5 allerdings auch erer mit
Verlusten die Sympathie für das
politische Personal bleibt insgesamt auf
einem niedrigen Niveau das dürfte der
Union die Suche nach einem
Kanzlerkandidaten erschweren im Herbst
soll die Entscheidung stehen und die
bisherigen Favoriten kommen nur mäßig
gut an NRW Ministerpräsident Hendrik wü
halten 36% nicht für kanzlertauglich 33%
dagegen schon wobei viele sich zu ihm
bisher kein Urteil bilden können etwa
ein Drittel Markus Söder wird die
kanzlereignung mehrheitlich abgesprochen
57% deutlich weniger trauen ihm das zu
38%. auch Friedrich März sieht die
Mehrheiten nicht geeignet als Kanzler
61%.
31%
schon die Union hat bisher also keinen
überzeugenden Herausforderer und kann
die Bundesregierung so kaum unter Druck
setzen obwohl die Ampel so schlecht
bewertet wird wie
nie Druck kommt diese Woche auch von den
Landwirten die sind sauer denn die Ampel
will ihnen Vergünstigungen streichen
zwar hat sie einige Kürzungen
zurückgenommen den Bauern geht das aber
nicht weit
genug 12% der Befragten finden die
ursprünglichen Kürzungen in Ordnung
32% sind für die teilweisen Kürzungen
wie sie jetzt geplant sind 52% meinen
für die Landwirte sollte es gar keine
Kürzungen geben ihre Blockaden und
Proteste in dieser Woche fanden 30%
übertrieben die meisten aber haben
Verständnis
68%. wegen der bauernproteste mussten
vor allem Anfang der Woche viele
Autofahrer umplanen ab Mittwoch dann
auch die Bahnfahrer wegen des Streiks
der
Lockführer
43% haben dafür Verständnis
54% nicht mehr als jeder
zweite wir schauen ins Ausland auf den
Nahostkonflikt im gazaastreifen geht
Israel weiter militärisch gegen die
Hamas vor und nimmt dabei viele zivile
Opfer in Kauf damit beschäftigt sich in
dieser Woche auch der Internationale
Gerichtshof ein Viertel hält das
Vorgehen Israels trotz der vielen
zivilen Opfer für gerechtfertigt
25%.
61%
nicht der Unmut über Israels Vorgehen
wird da deutlich den Wunsch nach
friedlicheren Zeiten im neuen Jahr
2024 werden die allermeisten
teilen das war unser Bericht über die
Stimmung im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite 165
in unserer zdfheute App und auf
zdfheute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
zustande kommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den
Qualitätsstandards finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zdf.de vielen Dank für
Ihr Interesse das nächste Politbarometer
gibt's dann am 2 Februar hier folgt
jetzt das Wetter und dann Aspekte ihnen
noch einen schönen Abend auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend das hochhnelore
ist heute weiter nach Westen gezogen und
machte den Weg frei für Hochnebel und
Wolken von Norden die brachten etwas
Nieselregen Schneegriesel und Schnee mit
und dann wurde es gefährlich glatt auf
den Straßen und mit Regen und Schnee und
in allen seinen Formen haben wir es auch
in den nächsten Tagen zu tun bevor dann
Anfang der komm Woche aus dem Regen mehr
und mehr Schnee wird machen Sie sich
also auf Glätte gefasst heute Nacht
besonders im Nordosten und auch in der
Mitte Deutschlands im Süden ist es zum
Teil klar dann bildet sich Nebel da kann
es dann reif glatt werden wenn der Nebel
an gefrorenen Boden festfriert und am
Alpenrand sinken die Temperaturen in den
strengen Frost von
-13° + 5° sind es auf den ostrischen
Insel die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen -2 und + 7° und das wird
für die die meisten von uns ein eher
drübertag auch morgen gibt's Schnee
Schneeregen Schneegriesel und
Nieselregen und es bleibt glatt auf
Straßen und Gehwegen auch wenn sich die
Glätte im Laufe des Tages mehr und mehr
in die Mittelgebirge zurückzieht an der
Nordsee rupft der kräftige Westwind die
Wolken auch mal auseinander auch
zwischen dem oberrein und dem allgol
werden sie die Sonne gut zu Gesicht
bekommen an diesem Wetter ändert sich
auch am Sonntag noch wenig die neue
Woche startet winterlich bevor es dann
am Mittwoch von Südwesten erst sehr
glatt und dann deutlich milder wird
guten Abend